it is so wonderful to see you know how
much at canada loves you
and you know for two years we have been
talking about your debut album
what does it feel like your music being
out there
and celebrating this moment i am
seriously just freaking out
to be able to share this season of my
life through this music and
it's really just such a crazy cool dream
and thank you guys for being excited
about it and
being on this adventure with me
appreciate you
[Music]
how would you describe what fans will go
through the journey they will go through
listening to this album
i hope it's exactly that a journey it's
like i was
you know really trying to craft the
sequence as we were working in the
studio
so that it could take people on a bit of
an emotional ride
be in isolation how has it been for you
has there been a lot of ups and downs
oh yeah i mean it's it's been hard and
heavy
with everything that's going on in in
the world and
i just i'm like missing the road so much
like i just
am dying to be back out there but i'm
i'm
trying to you know make the most of the
season and and
grateful for the time to sort of you
know recharge
so just sending so much love out there
to everybody i know this is just
such a hard time in general you're
talking about being on tour
you were on tour with dirks bentley and
miranda lambert like these guys are
huge did they give you any advice or any
steps going for what you should do with
your your career
oh absolutely it's it was such a dream
to get to open up
those shows and and really just have a
front row seat to watch and learn from
them every day
you know from the way that they take
care of people the way that their
their team works behind the scenes to
just make everyone feel welcome
and and the way that they make an entire
room feel welcome when they get on stage
and really
you know leave the charge with the music
so it was a wonderful thing to get to
watch
and and learn from them you know when we
talk about country music it's been at
the forefront for a while
in the last few months talking about the
lack of diversity talking about the fact
that
they don't play women's music as much on
country radio
for girls who are discouraged at the
idea of becoming a country singer what
would you say to them
the only way that i know how to keep
moving forward is to wake up every day
and
create music and do the thing that i
love to do it's like
i couldn't imagine doing anything else
no matter
how hard it is and for whatever reasons
that it's hard i think for anybody else
who shares that love it's like
just keep showing up and being who you
are and
i really do believe that that by doing
that you know the
the right doors will continue to open
and and and we'll get to be a part of
the
hopefully the reason that things keep
getting better i'm cheering for you out
there
i am too